in this video I want to cover several
topics that are all related and on some
level they're really simple but on a
whole other level they tend to confuse
people a lot so hopefully we can make
some headway so a good place to start
let's just imagine that I have some type
of container here let's say that's my
container and inside of that container I
have a bunch of water molecules it's
just got a bunch of water molecules
they're all rubbing against each other
it's in its liquid form this is liquid
water and then inside of the water
molecules I have some sugar molecules
maybe I'll do sugar in this pink color
so I have a bunch of sugar molecules
right here I have many many more water
molecules though I want to make that
clear I have many many more water
molecules in this container we're
dealing with now in this type of
situation we call we call the thing that
there's more of we call the thing that
there is more of the solvent so in this
case there's more water molecules and
you can literally just view more as the
number of molecules now I'm not going to
go into a whole discussion of moles and
all of that because you may or may not
have been exposed to that yet but just
imagine whatever there is more of that's
we're going to call the solvent so in
this case water is the solvent and
whatever there is less of so the more
water is a solvent and in this case that
is the sugar that is considered the
solute this is the solute so the sugar
it doesn't have to be sugar it could be
any molecule that there's less of than
the water in this case sugar is the
solute and we say that the sugar has
been dissolved into the water sugar has
been dissolved dissolved into into the
water and this whole thing right here
the combination of the water and the
sugar molecules we call a solution we
call this whole thing a solution
and a solution has solvent and the
solute the solvent is water that's the
thing doing the dissolving and the thing
that is dissolved is the sugar that's
the solute now all of this may or may
not be review for you but I'm doing it
for a reason because I want to talk
about I want to talk about the idea of
diffusion diffusion and the idea is
actually pretty straightforward if I
have let's say we'll say the same
container let me let me do in a slightly
different container here just to talk
about diffusion we'll go back to water
and sugar especially back to water let's
say we have a container here now let's
say it just has a bunch of let's say
just set some air particles in it could
be anything oxygen or carbon dioxide so
let me just draw a couple of air
molecules here so let's let's say that
that is a gaseous just for the sake of
argument gaseous oxygen so each of this
is an o2 each of those right now let's
say that this is the current
configuration that all of this is a
vacuum here that there's some
temperature so these water molecules
they have some type of they have some
type of kinetic energy they're moving in
some type of random directions right
there so my question is what is going to
happen what is going to happen in this
type of container well any of these guys
are going to be randomly bumping into
each other they're more likely to bump
into things in this down left direction
than they are in the upright direction
so if this guy was happening to go in
this down left direction he's going to
bump into something and then ricochet
into the up right direction but in the
upright direction there's nothing to
bounce into so in general everything is
moving in random directions but you're
more likely to be able to move in the
rightward direction when you go to the
left or more like we're going to bump
into each other into something so it's
almost common sense over time if you
just let this system come to some type
of equilibrium and I'm not going to go
into detail on what that means you can
watch the thermodynamics videos if you'd
like to see that you'll eventually see
the container will look something like
this I can't guarantee it there's some
probability it would actually stay like
this but very likely that those five
particles are going to get relatively
right out this is diffusion and so it's
really just the spreading of particles
or molecules from high concentration to
low concentration areas right in this
case the molecules are going to spread
in that direction from a high
concentration to low concentration area
now you're saying Sal what is
concentration and there's many ways to
measure concentration and you can go
into molarity and molality and all of
that but the very simple idea is how
much of that particle do you have per
unit space so here you have a lot of
those particles per unit space and here
you have very few of those particles per
unit space so this is a high
concentration and that's a low
concentration so you can imagine other
experiments like this you could imagine
a solution like let's let let's do
something like this let me make let's
say I have two containers let's say two
containers let's go back to the solution
situation so this was a gas but I
started off with that example so let's
stay with that example let's say that I
have a door right there that's larger
than either the water or the sugar
molecules on either side I have a bunch
of water molecules I have a bunch of
water molecules on either side just like
that on either side so I have a lot of
water molecules so if I just had water
molecules here they're all bouncing
around in random directions and so the
odds of a water molecule going this way
equivalent to ads of a water molecule
and going that way assuming that both
sides have the same level of water
molecule otherwise the pressures would
be different but let's say that you know
the top of this is the same as the top
of this so there's no more pressure
going in one direction or another
so you know if for whatever reason a
bunch of more water molecules we're
going in the rightward direction then
all of a sudden this would fill up with
more water and we know that that isn't
likely to occur so this is you know this
is just a solution with or this is just
a kind of two containers of water now
let's put some solute in it let's
dissolve some solute in it let's say we
do all the dissolving on the left hand
side so we put some sugar molecules on
the left hand side
and these are small enough to fit
through this little pipe that's one
assumption that I'm making so what's
going to happen all of these things have
some type of kinetic energy they're all
bouncing they're all bouncing around
well over time you know you you know the
water is going back and forth this water
molecule might go that way that water
molecule might go that way but they
Netta each other out but over time one
of these big sugar molecules will be
going in just the right direction to go
through maybe you know maybe this guy
instead of going in that direction he's
starts off going in that direction he
goes just through this through this up
this tunnel continued connecting the two
containers and he'll end up there right
and you know this guy will still be
bouncing around there's some probability
he goes back but there's still more
particles more sugar particles here than
there so still there's more probability
that one of so this guy's on that sub
something to cross them out but there's
still more probability that one of these
guys will go to that side then one of
these guys will go to that side so you
can imagine if you're doing this with
gazillions of particles I'm only doing
it with four over time the particles
will have spread out so that their
concentrations are roughly equal so that
you know maybe you'll have to hear over
time but if you're you know when you're
only dealing with three or four or five
particles you know there's some
probability it doesn't happen well
you're doing it a gazillion and they're
super small it's a very very very high
likelihood but anyway this whole process
we went from a container of high
concentration to a container of low
concentration and the particles would
have spread from the low concentration
container to the high concentration
container so they diffused this is
diffusion this is diffusion and just so
that we learn some other words that tend
to be used with the idea of diffusion
when we started off this had a higher
concentration the left-hand-side
container had higher concentration
higher concentration higher
concentration it's all relative right so
I'm higher than this guy higher
concentration and this right here had a
lower concentration lower concentration
and there are words for these things
this solution with a high concentration
is called a hypertonic solution let me
write that in yellow
Hyper hypertonic solution hyper in
general meaning a having a lot of
something having too much of something
and this lower constant concentration is
hypo hypo tonic hypotonic solution lower
concentration you might have heard maybe
one of your relatives if they haven't
had a meal in a while say I'm hypo
hypoglycemic that means that they have
not that they're feeling light-headed
there's not enough sugar in their
bloodstream and they want to pass out so
they want a meal if you you know you
just had a candy bar maybe your
hyperglycemic or maybe you're just hyper
in general but so these are just good
prefixes to know but hypertonic you have
a lot of the solute so you have high
concentration and then when hypotonic
not too much of the solute so you have a
low concentration these are good words
to know so in general diffusion if if
there's no barriers to the diffusion
like we had here you will have the
solute go from a high concentration or
hypertonic solution if they can travel
to a hypotonic solution to a hypo where
the concentration is lower now let's do
an interesting experiment here we've
talked about diffusion and so far we've
been talking about the diffusion of the
solute right and in general and this is
not always the case the you know if you
want to be as general as possible the
solute is whatever you have less of the
solvent is whatever you have more of and
the most common solvent tends to be
water but it doesn't have to be water it
could be some type of alcohol it could
be just you know it could be mercury it
could be a whole set of molecules but
water in most biological or chemical
systems tends to be the most typical
solvent it's what other things are
dissolved into but what happens if we
have a tunnel where the solute is too
big to travel but water is small enough
to travel so let's think about let's
think about that situation let's think
about say that situation in order to
think about it I'm going to do something
interesting let's say we have a
container here let's say we have
actually I won't even draw a container
let's just say we have an outside
environment
that has a bunch of water this is the
outside environment and then you have
some type of membrane you have some type
of membrane here
that's a membrane water can go in and
out of this membrane so it's
semipermeable well it's permeable to
water but the solute cannot go through
the membrane so let's say that the
solute is sugar so we have water on the
outside and also in Sun I want to do and
also inside the membrane so these are
little small water molecules this is a
membrane right here and let's say that
we have some sugar molecules again I
just I'm just picking on sugar it could
have been anything so we have some sugar
molecules here that are just a little
bit a little bit bigger or there could
be a lot bigger actually there are a lot
bigger than water molecules so you have
a bunch of and I only draw four but you
have a gazillion of them right but you
have a that much more water molecules
I'm just trying to show you have more
water molecules and sugar molecules and
this membrane is semipermeable semi
permeable permeable means that it allows
things to pass semipermeable means it's
not completely permeable so
semipermeable in this context I'm saying
I allow water to pass through the
membrane so water can pass water can
pass but sugar cannot sugar is too large
sugar cannot and the reason why in this
case is because the sugar molecule is
too big so if we were to zoom in on the
actual membrane itself maybe the
membrane looks like this I'm going to
zoom in on this membrane so I'm going to
zoom in on this membrane so it has
little holes in the membrane just like
that and maybe the water molecules are
about that size so they can go through
those holes so the water molecules can
go back and forth through the holes just
like that but the sugar molecules are
about that big so they cannot they
cannot go through that hole they're too
big for this opening right here to go
back and forth between them now what do
you think is going to happen in this
situation so first of all let's use our
terminology remember sugars are solute
waters are solvent semipermeable
membrane
side of the membrane has a higher or
lower concentration of solute well the
inside does the inside is hypertonic
hypertonic so I could write here hyper
hypertonic the outside has a lower
concentration so it's hypo hypo tonic
it's hypo tonic out here lower
concentration of solute
now if these openings were big enough
based on what we just talked about these
guys you know these guys are bouncing
around water is traveling in either
direction and II equal probability or
I'm gonna I'm actually I'm going to talk
about that in a second if everything was
wide open it would be equal probability
but if it was wide open these guys
eventually would bounce their ways over
to this side and you would probably end
up with equal concentrations eventually
and so you would had your traditional
diffusion where high concentration of
solute to low concentration of solute
but in this case these guys they can't
get they can't fit through the hole only
water can go back and forth if these
guys were not here if these guys were
not here water would have an equal
likelihood of going in this direction as
they would be going in that direction a
completely equal likelihood but because
because these guys are on the right-hand
side of or in this case on the inside of
our membrane this is our inside of our
membrane zoomed up these guys it's less
likely because these guys might be in
the kind of the approach position of the
holes it's less it's that slightly less
likely for water to be in the approach
position for the holes so it's actually
more probable that water could enter
then water exit and I want to make that
very clear if these sugar molecules were
not here obviously it's equally likely
for water to go in either directions now
that these sugar molecules are there
these sugar molecules might be on the
right hand side they might be blocking I
guess the best way to think about is
blocking the approach the hole they'll
never be able to go through the hole
themselves and not even be blocking the
hole but they're going in some random
direction so if a water molecule was
approaching it's that it's all
probabilistic and we're dealing with
gazillions of molecules it's that
much more likely to be blocked to get
outside but the water molecules from the
outside there's nothing blocking them to
get in so you're gonna have a flow of
water inside so in this situation with a
semipermeable membrane you're going to
have water you're gonna have a net
inward flow of water and so this is this
is kind of interesting we have the
solvent flowing from a hypotonic
situation to a hypertonic solution but
it's only hypotonic in the solute that's
when you talk about the solute it's only
hypertonic when you talk about the
solute but water if you if you flip it
the other way if you view sugar as the
solvent then you could say we're going
from a high concentration of water to a
low concentration of water I don't want
to confuse you too much this is what
tends to confuse people but just think
about what's going to happen no matter
what in what situation the solution is
going to do what it can to try to equal
liberate the concentration to make the
concentrations on both sides as close as
possible and it was it's not just some
magic it's not like the solution knows
it's all based on probabilities and
these things bumping around but in this
situation water is more likely to flow
into the container so it's actually
going to go from the hypotonic side when
we talk about low concentration of
solute to the side that has high
concentrations of solute of sugar and
actually if this thing is if this thing
is stretchable more water will flow flow
will keep flowing in and this and this
membrane will stretch out will stretch
out but we want to go into too much
detail here but this idea of water of
the solvent in this case water is the
solvent of thus of water as a solvent
diffusing through a semipermeable
membrane this is called osmosis osmosis
you've probably heard learning by
osmosis you know if you put a book
against your head maybe it'll just seep
into your brain
same idea that's where the word comes
from this idea of water seeping through
membranes to try to make concentrations
more equal so if you say well you have
high concentration here low
concentration here if there was no
membrane here these big molecules would
exit but because there's there's
this the semipermeable membrane here
they can't so the system just
probabilistically no you know not no
magic here more water will enter to try
to equal liberate the concentration and
you know eventually if maybe there's
maybe there's a maybe there's a few
molecules out here not as high
concentration here eventually if if all
if everything was allowed to happen
fully you'll get to the point where you
have just as many you have just as high
concentration on this side as you have
on the right-hand side because this
right-hand side is going to fill with
water and also probably become a larger
volume and then once again the
probabilities of a water molecule going
to the right and to the left will be the
same and you'll get to some type of
equilibrium but I want to make it very
clear diffusion is the idea of a of any
particle going from higher concentration
to and spreading into a region has a
lower concentration kind of just
spreading out osmosis is the diffusion
of water and usually you're talking
about you diffusion of water as a
solvent and usually it's in the context
of a semipermeable membrane where the
actual solute cannot travel through the
membrane anyway hopefully you found that
useful and not completely confusing